bonjour bon week-end bienvenue en basse
normandie
l'émotion est grande partout dans notre
pays mais également dans notre région
depuis quatre jours la france est en
deuil après ces attentats et ces prises
d'otages qui ont bouleversé le monde
entier le principal acte de barbarie
s'est produit mercredi au siège du
journal charlie hebdo douze morts dont
quatre dessinateurs de renom cabu
wolinski charb et keanu ce depuis quatre
jours nous sommes touche charlie et nous
avons décidé ce midi de consacrer un
numéro spécial de la voie est libre une
émission qui n'a peut-être jamais aussi
bien porté son nom puisque c'est la
liberté de parole c'est de la presse et
des dessinateurs qu'on a voulu
assassiner durant tout le week-end les
manifestations vont se multiplier
aux quatre coins de la région pour
rendre hommage aux victimes de cet
attentat
on va en parler dans quelques instants
avec nos invités à commencer par le
dessinateur chenu qui nous accompagne
tous les samedis bonjour chaunu mois
genre découvrent votre premier dessin
stéphane grimaldi est avec nous
également le directeur du mémorial de
caen un rassemblement a lieu en ce
moment devant le musée de la paix benoît
pichard vous êtes le directeur du préfet
du calvados et de basse normandie
un important dispositif de sécurité
était mis en place cette semaine
et enfin on reçoit également hassan
safoui vous représenter l'association
islamique et culturelle du calvados
merci à tous les quatre d'avoir répondu
à notre invitation
mais d'abord je vous disais ce sont des
milliers de van orman qui dès mercredi
soir sont descendus dans la rue pour
dire leur solidarité avec les victimes
de cet attentat de charlie hebdo vous
voyez ce reportage d'emilie flahaut
les réseaux sociaux ont fait leur
travail 7000 citoyens d'horizon ou de
confession différents lecteurs ou non de
charlie hebdo
tous unis pour dire non à la barbarie
ces personnes elles ont fait que c'est
en sorte que cette journée soit
extraordinaire par la barbarie et moi je
veux que nous français nous fassions de
cette journée une journée extraordinaire
par notre refus de cette barbarie et en
justement en faisant en sorte que les
ventes de charlie hebdo 11 en sorte que
toute la france soient bloqués pendant
10 ans on est tous derrière on a
vraiment envie que tout le monde soit
réuni ensemble fin c'est hyper important
tout le monde vraiment tout c'est la
liberté de la presse et c'est moi ça m'a
ça m'a tuer mon enfance charlie hebdo
c'est mes parents c'est il faut que tout
le monde se réunit ce jour deuil de mes
20 ans et de tout le reste
voilà ils ont envie m'ont accompagné
pendant toute ma vie oui mais bon
heureusement qu'ils nous ont permis de
penser ces gens là et voilà il me manque
parce que c'est elle et les plus grands
défenseurs de la liberté de penser ils
défendent et voilà le l'impertinence et
nécessaire dans notre société merde
la foule s'est ensuite déplacé dans les
rues de caen jusqu'à la place saint
sauveur
nouveau moment de recueillement à la
mémoire des victimes de l'attentât
avoue trivial regardez déjà j'avais raté
votre cou et l'aurait pas déçu au même
moment à lançon 400 personnes se
rassemblent dans la même unité place
lamagdeleine une émotion partagée sur
tout le territoire bas normands
puisqu'ils y a eu des rassemblements
avis religieux bayeux granville
coutances saint lô avranches ou encore
charbourg 500 personnes se sont
retrouvées place de la république avec
cette affiche devenu symbole de
résistance
je suis sur lui c'est le slogan que des
milliers de personnes de la région et de
français portent dans leur coeur depuis
mercredi soir stéphane grimaldi
vous êtes le directeur du musée mémorial
de caen en ce moment comment ça
rassemblement devant le musée de la paix
quel message justement vous souhaitez
porter après ce qui s'est passé cette
semaine écoutez il ya plusieurs messages
le premier c'est une de rendre hommage
non seulement à ces dessinateurs mais
pas seulement dessinateur toutes les
personnes qui ont été tuées notamment
les fonctionnaires de police
et puis de rendre hommage à ces à ces
personnes et je crois que l'hommage a
été nationale et au delà et ça c'est une
très bonne chose parce qu'il a été
spontanée silencieux humble la deuxième
chose c'est en effet de dire que
nous résisterons nous résisterons à 7
cette espèce de violence pure gratuites
cegid et voilà ça lui lorsqu'il fait que
ces différences manière on l'a vu une
manie 13 horrifiante cette semaine avec
cet attentat
au siège de charlie hebdo mais également
une violence plus sournoise sur des
sites internet dont vous avez été
victime d'une violence qui vous a visé
en plein coeur aussi puisque le site du
mémorial de caen était touchée il y aura
des hauts il dit oui le site a été
piraté hier ils sont entrés dans notre
site ils ont qu'a raté notre site etc
mais j'ai pas envie de m'étendre là
dessus pour toutes sortes de raisons
mais ça veut dire qu'il s'installe une
espèce de violence sournoise et le le
vrai et le vrai message de de votre
émission mon avis c'est en effet de dire
que nous ne devons pas avoir peur
pas question d'avoir peur il est
question de faire face dit faire
confiance en l'état important
fondamentale dont je vais m'adresser
jusque loin et puis de se rapprocher de
nos concitoyens musulmans juifs
chrétiens et c est de montrer que la
france est une nation alors y aura une
nation une et indivisible on va l'évoqué
justement au cours de cette émission
benoît puis ça vous êtes le directeur de
cabinet du préfet du calvados et de la
basse-normandie faire confiance à l'état
disait stéphane grimaldi à l'instant il
s'est passé quelque chose depuis
mercredi alors certains journaux ont
titré un 11 septembre à la française je
sais pas s'il faut aller jusque là il ya
débat sur la question mais la
responsabilité de l'état et le rôle de
l'état n'a jamais été aussi fort aussi
évident il réunit depuis mercredi
d'abord je voudrais vous dire que on y
étiez on était mercredi soir que ce
préfet à ce rassemblement puis on a
rencontré les gens qui étaient présents
pour pour partager ce moment où on
sentait que la situation
c'est un moment d'émotion quand vous
l'avez dit assez intense immense et on a
senti cette cette mobilisation spontanée
des citoyens qui faisait un acte de
résistance un acte de résistance par
rapport à 7
cette terreur à cette barbarie et je
vous dirais que aujourd'hui tous les
témoignages que l'on pouvait avoir des
personnes rassemblées était de dire on
compte on compte sur vous on compte sur
l'état et voilà l'état on sait que et on
va en parler un peu après dans cette
émission se préparer à de tels attentats
via un dispositif qui est en place dans
notre région
au regard des événements qu'on a connu
le 70e anniversaire du débarquement les
jeux équestres mondiaux
est ce que ces alertes quelque part nous
arriverons en pleine figure
est-ce que ici en basse normandie
quelque part on n'a plus confiance du
traumatisme parce que il ya une histoire
certainement mais je voudrais revenir
sur un point important est un dispositif
qui s'appelle vigipirate vigipirate et
de la vigilance et cylia dispositif qui
est mis en place
cathay renforcer notamment volé a
rappelé pour notamment le 70e
anniversaire ou les jeux équestres
mondiaux c'est pas pour rien c'est que
il ya parfois des cires des actes de
menaces qui qui qui existe est donc
aujourd'hui notre devoir notre
responsabilité c'est de savoir aller
prévenir au maximum
je dirais de les maîtriser pour que tous
les jours les services de l'état sont
mobilisés
voilà cette ville cette cette posture
vigipirate peut-être qu'aujourd'hui elle
est tombée dans le langage dans le
langage courant des jambes on n'y prête
pas forcément attention
aujourd'hui on a un focus particulier
données sur 7 sur cette posture
vigipirate où les gens ne sont plus
attentifs à ce qui se passe et ils ont
raison parce que je suis d'accord avec
vous monsieur passe où je peux pas céder
à la peur la peur c'est pas faux pas ne
faut pas lui donner faut pas que cette
peur soit synonyme de plus dense voilà
aujourd'hui on demande aux gens d'être
prudent non on va revenir peut-être tout
à l'heure dans les oasis
puisqu'il ya mille trois cents gendarmes
et policiers qui sont déployés depuis
mercredi dans le seul département du
calvados
il ya un certain nombre d'établissements
qui sont sous surveillance
ici nous france trois organes de presse
mais bon des sosies de deux fouilles de
filtrage l aider des gens il s'est passé
quelque chose
depuis mercredi la vie a changé c'est lé
mali vous refusez que l'ovale d'un 11
septembre vous qui êtes à la tête de ce
musée de la pêche ça n'est pas un 11
septembre à la france va d'abord c'est
prématuré il ya le 11 septembre c'est un
dans l'histoire du monde c'était un
c'est une balance il ya eu un avant et
un après en septembre et nous sommes
toujours en vérité dans l'après en
septembre il ya une guerre en
afghanistan était là il est prématuré de
dire que ces attentats cette semaine en
france ouvre une nouvelle histoire alors
dans nos coeurs oui dans nos consciences
nationales oui bien sûr mais d'un point
de vue historique
ça me semble très prématuré alors parmi
les 12 victimes
il eut à quatre dessinateurs de charlie
hebdo cabu wolinski charb et in your sur
les îles a rappelé on va voir quelle que
soit leur image connue vous êtes le
dessinateur attitré de cette mission la
question j'ai envie de vous poser
d'abord elle est humaine je dirai ce que
vous connaissiez kim est ce que vous les
avez côtoyé peut-être au mémorial les
colloques les événements qu'il ya pu y
avoir d'abord le mémorial est un lieu de
rencontres avec les rencontres pour les
dessinateurs donc nous les avions
rencontrés c'était un moment de joie
parce qu on communie avec le public
dernière fois que j'ai vu georges
wolinski c'est à brive à la foire du
livre georges était tout seul à sa table
est un homme très discret savez ces gens
il ya un décalage entre leurs traits la
violence qu'ils ont dans leur dans l'or
dans leurs dessins et et en étant ce
qu'ils sont profondément et cabu est un
homme délicieux mais voyez-vous franck
nous aurions dû aujourd'hui disposer le
studio d'une autre façon regardez moi
j'aurais dû me remettre à côté
de notre ami qui est ici présents qui
représente les musulmans c'est loin de
la région parce que regarder ce qui
s'est passé et ça c'est un message ces
gens ont raté quelque chose je pense
les premiers qui sont venus sur se
recueillir c'est le recteur de la
mosquée de paris et le cettex grand
homme qui est l'imam de drancy et moi je
me réjouis d'avoir avec nous ici à leur
présentant des musulmans parce que nous
n'allons pas tomber dans ce piège
grossier
parce que ces gens ne sont pas des
croyants ils se réclament de rien du
tout ils sont d'ailleurs le produit de
la société moderne
la société de la violence des images etc
et en rien ses d'une culture millénaire
c'est une atteinte de la presse
également la liberté de dessiner on va
voir quelques images de cabu qui était
une des victimes et des premières
victimes d'ailleurs de l'attentât de
charlie hebdo il était venu il ya
quelques années au mont saint michel
c'était un caricaturiste c'est le métier
que vous exercez oui c'est plus que ça à
cabu cabu c'est véritablement certains
caricaturistes mais c'était aussi un
dessinateur populaire
cabu et est capable d'avoir créé avec
goscinny la banda pilote le grand
duduche il était la plus grande le pays
on parle de charlie hebdo mais c 'est
voyez vous je parle toujours c'est le
plus grand traite du canard et en même
temps c'était l'homme qui avait accepté
de dessiner pour le club dorothée la
bande à dorothée et là vous avez un
homme qui était capable de s'ouvrir
totalement sans posture donc en tuant
cabut on tue un très très grand artiste
un pan de notre culture est aussi un pan
de l'histoire parce que il était
toujours 7 and art et qui n'aimait pas
les curés les bonnes soeurs et le
général de gaulle et c'est quelque chose
d'autre qui l'a tué venus d'ailleurs
qu'une fait d'ailleurs absolument pas
partie de notre culture et de notre et
de nos racines républicaine voilà ça
c'est ce drame absolu avoir perdu je
dirais wolinski cabu charb était un
hussard quelqu'un qui montaient soul
avec la mitraille il attendait presque
cela et perdre cabu c'est moi mon coeur
saigne vraiment vraiment vraiment on
sait que charlie hebdo et ses
dessinateurs
mais pas toujours eu des amis chez les
musulmans depuis notamment les
caricatures de 2006 ces fameuses
caricatures de mahomet on entend
plusieurs personnalités notamment dans
le monde musulman dire par le dessin on
doit répondre par le dessin on doit pas
répondre par les armes par le terrorisme
à 5 safri vous êtes un des représentants
de l'association islamique et culturelle
du calvados est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec tous ceux qui partagent
cet avis justement c'est exactement ça
ce qui s'est passé certains crimes
odieux d'une barbarie son nom qui est
venu comme vous l'avez très bien dit
d'ailleurs avec un logiciel qui n'est
absolument pas qu'il prend pas ses
racines dans dont les références
musulmane loin de là et tout le danger
c'est de nourrir les amalgames et de
considérer que ce qui s'est passé se
réclameraient d'une quelconque religion
et encore moins de la religion musulmane
bien sûr on répond dessin par le dessin
on peut aussi répondre au dessin par les
tribunaux s'il le faut si on n'est pas
d'accord c'est ça une société
démocratique et libre la liberté
d'expression se se protège à la fois de
ses propres excès mais aussi de son
manquement et je peux vous dire que ce
qui ce dont souffre beaucoup de peuples
aujourd'hui c'est le manque de liberté
et non pas la libre on a parlé au début
de cette émission de cet élan de
solidarité cette vague qui a emporté
toute la france des gens qui sont
capables de se rassembler spontanément
7000 personnes en quelques heures dans
le centre-ville de caen vous étiez
présent je crois que j'évolue soir j
étais j'étais présent avec beaucoup de
membres de l'association parce qu'on ne
peut pas accepter que des criminels
strain comme slogan comme étendard
l'islam ou alors parce que ils ont
proféré des vocables musulmans lors de
l'heure de leur forfait de leur macabre
massacre qui conte les reconnaîtrais
coco musulmans c'est journal ne
représentent en rien en religion ne
représente en réalité musulman
nous sommes horrifiés par ce qui s'est
passé des gens qui sont partis
travailler sur sur leur lieu de travail
on vient les éliminer de sang froid
c'est innommable et san roque l'onu et
ça ne peut c'est un logiciel venus
d'ailleurs que je tiens ici on veut
aussi nous faire glisser vers
l'antisémitisme paire de 10
les musulmans sont contre les juifs le
roi du maroc est un juste parmi les
nations il a protégé les juifs du maroc
attention à ces amalgames et vous avez
parfaitement raison
ces trucs là sont des ovnis ça ne fait
pas partie de la culture française et de
son ancien empire
écoutez je suis désolé nous avons eu un
empire si vous permettez au niveau des
associations musulmanes et au niveau des
mosquées le problème c'est que ces
gens-là ne fréquente pas nos mosquées
très bien bien bien que bien fort celui
qui nous démontrera qu'il y aura un lien
avec nos monstres avec nos proches nos
imams ces gens là ils sont devant des
gouro ils sont victimes de des cyber
secte qui se réclament de l'islam
ce sont des criminels et une
condamnation à deux ans l'ensemble sans
engagement quel regard vous portez sur
le travail de charlie hebdo qui avait
l'habitude de faire des satires du
peuple est musulman et du prophète le
mot mais on va voir peut-être le dernier
dessin de chats paru mercredi avec cette
légende toujours pas d'attentât en
france on a jusqu'à la fin janvier pour
présenter ses voeux
c'est assez triste parler d'un dessin
très prémonitoire
c'est triste le problème c'est que les
dessins de charlie hebdo peuvent mériter
en tant que musulmans peuvent déranger
mais en aucun cas je me mettrais du côté
de ce criminel il raison dérange et
parfois elles en ont bien sûr c'est tout
à fait naturel et ça dérange beaucoup de
musulmans mais justement la pédagogie
consistait à dire que la liberté
d'expression est un est un bien très
cher qui nous est très cher ici en
france on doit le préserver y compris en
s'adressant peut-être en critiquant ses
dessins j'imagine que c'est quelque
chose que vous partagez stéphane
grimaldi
ce devoir de paix que l'on n'a que vous
relayer à la travers ce musée mémorial
on est à six mois de la date
anniversaire
du événements du 6 juin du débarquement
aujourd'hui on apprend que il ya cet
attentat se préserver justement de la
lutte des religions et de ce qu'on a
connu il ya 70 ans
c'est le message que vous souhaitez
faire porter j'imagine aussi vous savez
le message qu'on essaie de faire passer
aux centaines de milliers de personnes
aux millions de personnes qui sont
venues au mémorial c'est que la paix est
fragile et fait que nous vivons dans un
monde occidental extraordinairement
confortable qui nous émeut aujourd'hui
arrive tous les jours aujourd'hui en
irak et il ne faut pas se bercer
d'illusions c'est tout il faut que nos
concitoyens que nous-mêmes acception
l'idée que la paix et le bien universel
le plus fragile et plus vrai cette peine
fonctionne pardonnez moi
il faut en effet que les gens se
respectent le le maître mot c'est le
respect le respect de l'autre le respect
de la religion de l'autre le respect de
la parole de l'autre le respect du
visage de l'autre est ce qu'il y aura un
espace dédié justement à charlie hebdo
peut-être au sein du mémorial et c'est
quelque chose auquel vous réfléchissez
je suis charlie est ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer au moment du 11 septembre vous
avez créé un espace au mémorial de caen
est ce que demain on pourra voir un
espace charlie hebdo
on a fait une exposition sur le 11
septembre pour expliquer que l'on
septembre avait été une bascule dans
l'histoire du monde
on va réunir en avril prochain
une trentaine de dessinateurs de presse
du monde entier au mémorial comme on le
fait depuis cinq ans on va voir voilà on
va réfléchir avec eux on va travailler
avec eux alors ne pas créer la psychose
c'est ce qu'on entend depuis quelques
jours la baston monde y est en plan
vigipirate
on le disait il ya quelques minutes
benoît pichat depuis le printemps
dernier et depuis que l'on prépare
l'organisation du 70e anniversaire du
débarquement
on l'a vu des milliers personnes des
millions de personne d'ailleurs cet été
également le déferlé sur les sites
touristiques
on a entendu dire que plusieurs
attentats avaient été déjoués sur le sol
français
excusez moi de vous poser la question
est ce que depuis et je sais pas si vous
êtes autorisés à y répondre mais je vous
la pose quand même
est ce que on a eu à déjouer des
attentats dans notre région depuis mars
dernier
pas à ma connaissance donc je ne crois
pas pendant notre région très je tairai
ce sont des services du renseignement
intérieur qui sont plus à même que moi
de vous donner cette réponse précise
mais je crois pas qu'ils soient
habilitées à le dire mais comme vous le
dites je pense qu'aujourd'hui mais les
forces de l'ordre depuis printemps
dernier mais non seulement depuis le
printemps dernier mais depuis les fêtes
de fin d'année où les consignes du
ministère de l'intérieur était très
clair depuis quelques jours là depuis
quelques jours
depuis et ces périodes de fêtes depuis
les attentats sur des sur des marchés de
noël notamment quelques biens des gens
bien avant bien avant
depuis que voilà les gens sortaient de
plus en plus nombreux dans les
centre-villes dans les centres
commerciaux dans les espaces de gare
sncf et des consignes très claires
comme chaque année où nous devons être
vigilants renforcer l'existant
concrètement qu'est ce qui s'est passé
depuis mercredi depuis mercredi
bien sûr le plan vigipirate est toujours
actif l'a pas été je tirais pas passer à
un niveau supérieur
contrairement à la région ile-de-france
mais tout cas on nous a demandé d'être
d'autant plus vigilant sur des espaces
bien précis vous l'avez précisé par
exemple les rédactions mais également si
je dirais utilement devant france 3 où
il ya des débris de verre où les
véhicules sont fouillés propos des
défauts parce que l'information on a
pris attache auprès de chaque rédaction
les forces de police sont appelés ou
rappelés chaque rédaction pour voir
s'ils souhaitaient un dispositif
particulier donc ça a été mis en place
vous avez demandé un barriérage autour
d'eux au studio il a été fait mais c'est
également le cas je tairai auprès des
centres commerciaux près des principales
gares du département et puis je tairai
les bâtiments qui accueillent du public
et puis les lieux de culte depuis jeudi
soir
j'ai donné des instructions très claires
services de police pour que entre autres
les mosquées du département fasse
l'objet d'une surveillance particulière
pour vendredi entre autres jours de
prière donc les services de police sont
mobilisées particulièrement est ce qu'on
a
en fait une date qui correspondrait à la
fin du dispositif ou est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui peut durer
là pendant plusieurs semaines et
aujourd'hui à l'heure où je vous parle
j'ai pas de consigne qui donne une fin
le dispositif en quoi conquête le
dispositif logistique dessus tout de
même à part ces points de vigilance
particulier qu'on nous a demandé de
surveiller davantage chez elle le
dispositif est exactement le même
qu'auparavant
ceci dit petite nuance aujourd'hui
depuis le vendredi matin
huit militaires sont venus renforcer des
patrouilles de police notamment sur le
secteur du centre-ville de caen et sur
le secteur de de la gare sncf et ce
dispositif a été jusqu'à maintenant mis
en place jusqu'à la fin janvier
est ce que vous dites ce midi ils vont
répéter d'ailleurs depuis mercredi c'est
ne cédez pas à la psychose
on ferait le jeu d'ailleurs je pourrais
poser la question aux différents invités
et ne cédez pas à la psychose
on ferait le jeu des terreaux et c'est
ça le message malgré les renforcements
des forces de sécurité sur le terrain
malgré les policiers les gendarmes les
militaires qui sont arrivés ne faut pas
céder à cette fête les rangs sécurisé
également les gens pour leur dire et on
sécurise les gens à l'heure où jusqu
alors on a demandé ce concours de police
d'être présent pour que je dirais les
rassemblements qui se dérouleront
aujourd'hui principalement dans le
département du calvados se passe je
dirais dans de très bonnes conditions
pour que n'y ait aucun débordement
puisque ça peut en exister et aucune
menace alors on a parlé d'atteinte à la
liberté d'expression la liberté de la
presse
chaunu vous exercer ce métier j'ai
horreur de libres penseurs
est ce que à un moment un autre vous
êtes sentis menacés dans votre exercice
d'abord je n'ai jamais été menacé m en
exercice où il ya toujours des grincheux
voilà mais bon vous savez quand même on
a passé un palier et là plus rien ne
sera comme avant mais j'aurais quand
même rappeler une chose c'est que quand
je dis plus rien de ça comme avant ne
sera plus comme avant c'est que en
france
bien sûr c'est une première je vous
rappelle qu'il ya eu un massacre
terrible au pakistan et vous souvenez ce
carnage dans cette école est que nous
sommes tous victimes de c2c de lundi
passé fou parce qu'ils ne sont pas des
fous mais je peux vous dire une chose
c'est que là on est encore sur le coup
de l'émotion
mais on ne pourra pas se priver d'une
grande réflexion qui me paraît
d'ailleurs plus importante que des packs
de responsabilité et c'est parce que ça
touche notre société ça touche le socle
républicain et je crois quand même qu'on
va devoir faire un dialogue inter
religieux on d'aller au devant de de
l'islam
on ne peut plus faire l'autruche il
s'agit pas de ceux de se déculotter face
à sète a déplu à des puissances mais on
va être obligés à partir de maintenant
d'avoir un grand débat national pour que
ces enfants que nous avons couver ses
enfants de banlieue que nous avons
prouvé
eh bien on puisse ils remettent dans le
droit chemin parce que sinon ça va être
une hémorragie voilà benoît fischer
voulu intervenir juste un mot c'est vrai
qu'on a franchi ce palier comme vous
l'avez des également pour les forces de
l'ordre
aujourd'hui elles ont été massacrés
willeman ses vrais fonctionnaires de
police ont été exécutés froidement et je
ne jure que leur sens chez les
fonctionnaires c'est qu'on ressent c'est
effectivement dur mais quel est l'état
d'esprit bus devant pour aller un peu
d'esprit est toujours le même jour il
fonctionnerait police s'ils sont là pour
assurer leurs missions et la sueur jour
et nuit fait chaud lui disait quelque
chose a changé c'est ce qu'on a répété
depuis le début de l'émission depuis
mercredi soir
est-ce que vous aussi dans vos cordes et
à chez les fonctionnaires de police de
gendarmerie quelque chose a changé
je tairai il ya cette chose qui est
encore plus présente qu'avant c'est
cette prudence et cette vigilance
elle est d'autant plus présente
aujourd'hui qu'elle l'était auparavant
s'il ya un lien s'il ya un lien à faire
entre les attentats du 11 septembre
est ce que nous venons de vivre en
france c'est celui d'une guerre à
l'étranger celui de ces fous qui se
réclame d'un groupe terroriste
internationalement connue aïda et qui
viennent commettre ses forfaits ici en
france et donc il faudrait pas que ce
qui s'est passé face changer nos
habitudes nos habitudes de liberté et
nous fasse nous fasse tomber dans les
bras l islamophobie galopante qui met à
l'index la présence musulmane en france
c'était pas grave a dit je vous ai posé
la question des luttes et des missions
qu'est ce qui se passe demain comment on
réagit quels messages justement on porte
à travers cette manifestation qui
commence en ce moment devant le mémorial
de caen
que se passe-t-il demain justement après
ces attentats après cette horreur devant
devant le siège de charlie hebdo espacil
demain où ça en france oui lesquelles
prise de conscience on assure sais rien
je sais rien moi je moi je crois que je
crois que le lot on perd six si on cède
à cette menace on dit tout
on a dit si tu sais déjà une banalité de
le dire il faut pas céder à cette menace
il faut que notre république reste
stable
il faut qu'elle reste stable il faut
comme le dit manuel on soit peut-être
davantage dans un dialogue dans une
compréhension etc mais certainement pas
certainement passer d une espèce de peur
panique collective qu'on a remarqué ça
aussi c'est encore le relire mais cette
solidarité entre les ai fait remarquer
ce qu'il ya quelque chose de formidable
qui s'est passé le soir du crime
c'est que les gens sont descendus
spontanément dans la rue ils n'ont pas
eu besoin ni partis politiques de
syndicats ni de maudore n'y a de rien du
tout et ça ça veut dire que notre peuple
que nous sommes capables ou français de
nous relever
ce qui n'était jamais arrivé bah si
c'est arrivé dans les grands moments
d'histoire de france mais là il s'est
passé quelque chose il s'est passé est
un événement spontané populaire
rassembleur avec des musulmans des
catholiques des juifs etc
tout n'est tous ces gens qui étaient
dans la rue ne lui sont pas des lecteurs
de charlie hebdo
je suis charlie tout le monde on peut
reprendre le slogan c'est la fin de set
et gestion / stéphane n'oublions pas que
la tunisie vient de nous donner un
exemple de démocratie
et ça gêne énormément et la tunisie
c'est la famille maroc algérie tunisie
et va écouter ces deux côtés de la
méditerranée
1 c'est la famille alors après voilà et
n'oublions pas aussi une chose franck 1
journée le mari le legal le garde du
corps je vais me le garde du corps de
charb était le mari d'une des
rédactrices d'un des journaux le pays
d'auge
vous voyez cette espèce de symboles
journaliste est aussi un policier vous
avez bien fait de manière ce qu'on a
voulu faire lui rendre hommage à ces
victimes
il tentera de charlie hebdo mercredi
soir merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
spontanément
et rapidement accepté notre invitation
nous avons un peu bouleversé nos
programmes à une autre thématique de la
voie est libre cette semaine et france
télévisions a décidé de rendre hommage
justement aux victimes de mercredi
dernier de cet attentat merci bon
week-end et à samedi prochain
et
tout